gelähmte die wieder gehen können nein
kein wunder dass es medizin bild war
exklusiv dabei bei einer ganz neuen
operation die querschnittsgelähmten neue
hoffnung gibt es ist der moment den
siegfried vogl zweifacher familienvater
aus nrw so herbei gesehnt hat der
querschnittsgelähmte er spürt wieder
etwas in seinen beinen und das nach
einem unfall der sein leben verändert
hat
ich hatte 2009 10 august 2009 10 ein
fahrrad und voller mountainbike-unfall
binder beim downhill sehr schwer
gestürzt und habe mir die wirbelsäule
gebrochen am brustwirbel fünf bin seit
dem korsett brusthöhe
querschnittsgelähmt der 51-jährige war
fan von extremsport wandern
motorradfahren das alles ist vorbei ein
leben wie vor dem unfall unmöglich doch
es gibt einen lichtblick hoffnung dass
siegfried vogel endlich wieder laufen
kann am leben teilhaben kann und wenn
man einfach nur stehen kann wenn man
einfach drei vier schritte gehen kann
wieder wenn man sich wieder dem leben an
gehörig fühlt das gibt einem so viel und
all die hoffnung liegt auf ihm professor
marc kosova chirurg aus zürich mit
seiner bosse wehrlein methode kann der
patienten wie siegfried vogl hoffnung
geben ihnen helfen mit krücken oder
rollator wieder zu laufen alles durch
eine einzige operation wir haben per
bauchspiegelung das heißt auf minimal
invasiv wegen mit schlüsselloch lösche
durch den bauchnabel
die haben installations- elektroden an
die wichtige becken nerven die für das
aufstehen umgehen zuständig sind und
diese elektroden wir verbunden an den
schrittmacher welcher ebenfalls den
körper implantiert wurde untere hat die
haut und mit dieser schrittmacher werden
wir die namen stimulieren für die mieten
für die training der muskel und
irgendwann das wiedererlangen des
aufstehenden
doch wie von allein gehen kann man
dadurch noch nicht die muskeln müssen
über wochen mit stromstößen die durch
ein tablet gesteuert werden trainiert
werden erst dann sind laufversuche
ermöglicht bei 70 der patienten von
professor pozzo wer sind erfolge zu
vermelden sie sind ihrem alten leben
schon einen großen schritt näher
gekommen darauf hofft auch siegfried
vogl weshalb er sich für die 85.000 euro
teure operation entschieden hat
[Musik]
siegfried vogel wird in den
operationssaal gebracht unterzieht sich
der mehrstündigen op bei professor posse
wer bekommt den helfenden schrittmacher
im bauchraum eingesetzt nur kurze zeit
nach der operation wie durch ein wunder
siegfried vogel kann seine beine bewegen
nur wenige stunden nach dem
komplizierten eingriff zu sehen dass das
funktioniert
dass die beiden sich bewegen war schon
echt echt klasse sind sehr sehr schönes
gefühl
besonders gilt ein hauch sturm das da
langfristig da was passiert wo ich habe
ein ziel wieder ruhig darauf hinarbeiten
kann es ist die hoffnung die hoffnung
auf bewegung die hoffnung auf die
rückkehr zu seinem alten leben
[Musik]